So we talked to Muriel about
vitamins versus painkillers, and
I wanted to ask you this same question.
What do you think is better for
an entrepreneur when he
thinks about types of ideas.
Vitamins or painkillers?
>> It's funny.
I don't really think about it in those
terms, but I guess the way I think
about it is kind of the same way.
I would say the pain killer
is a much bigger deal.
But even more than the pain killer, I
think you want like a life saving drug.
>> Right.
>> You want something that someone
really, really needs.
My partner Paul Buheight said way
better to build something that
a few people love than a lot
of people sort of like.
>> Right.
>> And so that's what we look for.
It's something that people really,
really want.
Because those are going to be your
initial core of passionate users
who are going to engage
with you sufficiently
to help you develop your product and
make it better.
If you just have something
that people kind of like,
they'll use it a couple of times and
then they'll go away.
And if your initial users just go away,
you're left with a ghost town.
>> Right.
>> I think that the biggest challenge
for startups, people talk about, you
know, you are going to run out of money.
You're going to this or that..
I think the biggest problems that most
startups have, you run out of time.
And part of the reason you run out
of time is because you're fighting
the apathy of the market.
It's not that people know about you and
don't like you,
it's that no one has
any idea who you are.
And if you solve something that is
a really deep pain for someone,
they're going to talk about you.
So forget all the conversation about
viral marketing, this kind of marketing,
that kind of marketing, these tactics.
If you solve something really important
to someone, they're going to mention it.
>> Can you give me an example
of a vitamin and a painkiller?
>> Yeah, I think that again it's this
idea of it's different things for
different people.
I think Stripe's a pretty good
example of the pain killer.
Integrating payments into a website.
Is such a big pain in the butt
without something like Stripe.
I remember when we integrated PayPal it
took days and weeks just to like, they
didn't even have developer documents
that you could read in any kind of way.
>> Right
>> And it took weeks and
to get this and the that and
the other thing.
It was a nightmare.
Stripe's a couple lines of code and
you have payment set up.
For some people, if you're not building
a website that seems like a vitamin.
It seems like a nice to have.
But in terms of supportability, and all
these things, and ease of use, that's
a huge painkiller for anyone building
something for e-commerce, honestly.
>> Very cool.
>> In terms of vitamins, I don't know,
there's kind of a lot of them.
Not to say and some of them are probably
really successful companies or
become successful over time, but
I think that they are,
they don't scale quite as quickly.
You know an incremental hair
dresser closer to your house.
>> Right.
>> You know five miles
closer is a vitamin.
>> Right.
>> You can drive another five mile.
When it comes to software,
there are a lot of things out there.
If you look at the app charts,
you probably see a lot of them.